Now that we have gone over these
different types of ideas, I'd like you
to hear about a company and decide which
of these ideas apply to that company.
The first company is called Shyp.
Shyp is a company that allows
users to send mail and
packages to anyone in the world.
Users can choose an item,
take a picture of it on their phone, and
then set a destination and
schedule a pickup.
Shyp takes care of the rest by picking
up the item and finding the lowest cost,
and most reliable way to send
the package, pretty seamless.
So which type of ideas do you
think apply to the company Shyp?
Check all of these idea types that
you think apply to the company.